I'm quite thrilled to hear that the
left's doing so well cuz it doesn't look
like that from our angle that we we you
know we we've conquered the universities
and uh We've conquered the it really
doesn't feel like
[Music]
it if we accept the premise that
objectivity is never quite possible but
as Phil said you know we should be
striving for it what would be a healthy
alternative and my my answer to that
would be that we have a Public Square or
a national conversation that is as
intellectually diverse um and vibrant as
possible that we we genuinely have um a
range of views and perspectives and
beliefs and voices within that National
conversation so at least we can um
interrogate uh and explore um you know
various truths as we we see them um but
that is not happening today uh that is
partly why we saw the political uh
volatility of the last 13 years it's why
2024 um will will likely be a a sort of
return to 2016 in many ways because many
voters out there are looking at the
media and have been looking at the media
class and increasingly
feel that uh that Viewpoint diversity
you know we talk endlessly about
diversity except when it comes to inter
ual diversity and Viewpoint diversity
isn't really there uh and that's also
True by the way where where I work the
universities and if you look for example
at Britain's universities the ratio of
of leftwing to right-wing academics has
gone from 3 to one in the 1960s to
closer to 10 to one today I do think
that's a problem so within the context
of this National conversation I think
we've lost something quite special uh
which is why the media landscape as I
say is fragmenting at the at the pace at
which it is I mean if you look at our
Flagship media programs Radio 4 today
lost 2 million listeners since brexit
you look at the rise of new entrance as
I say GB News Talk TV uh YouTube online
space and so on um all of that and and
also by the way the collapse of public
confidence in media all of that I think
is reflective of the way in which many
voters have now come to the conclusion
that the Viewpoint diversity that should
be there that should be giving
expression to values that are held by
much of the rest of the country but are
not necessarily held by the people in
the corridors of power is not really is
not really there uh so the the
alternative in my mind would be
reforming the
institutions ensuring that people who
are in the media class are not just the
Sons and Daughters of senior journalists
that we actually have a serious
sustained attempt to get different
voices and values onto the comment pages
into the newspap papers into the
universities that uh the epistemic class
which determines what is socially
acceptable and what is not socially
acceptable is is broadened out and I
think that in turn would would perhaps
get us closer to this this this idea of
having a vibrant Public Square go for it
Phil I agree we want the most the widest
possible plurality of voices and range
of opinion I agree too that it's
narrower than it should be but one of
those range one of those opinions I want
in there one of those ways of
approaching information is to have some
impartial voices that's precisely what I
think where I think it sits that um I
don't think being entirely objective and
being impartial and quite the same thing
either but to have within the landscape
of enormously proliferating voices some
institutions who have a public service
regulatory obligation to seek to tell
the truth truth as they see it whilst we
accept if we're going to erect a high
philosophical standard we're going to
judge them as failures I think that's a
really weak reason for not trying that I
think there's very significant successes
in British journalism with respect to
the reporting of the news it is I repeat
a very different thing from offering an
opinion none of us are under any
obligation to be impartial it would be a
very boring debate if we were this is an
exchange of views there's no requirement
for impartiality here quite the country
but when you're reporting the news on
the 6:00 news the 10:00 news to then
attempt as far as you can to tell the
truth as it is and say nothing that is
not true and to weigh it for news value
these are noble things to do they do not
amount to an absolutely definitive and
determinate idea of impartiality of
course they don't but there nevertheless
it's still different for what I do in
the times and I think I think that's the
Central Point here that within that
plurality there is space for that kind
of institution one other point is I I
take the point that the plurality isn't
as wise as it should be but firstly I
think that the online journalism has
proliferated it enormously I think that
the days in which it's quite interesting
we're here a couple of days after Rupert
Murdoch steps down uh from the top job
at news UK in a sense is the end of an
era um the notion that the the media
that I worked in exercises the kind of
power they claimed when they claimed the
sun won the 1992 general election I
think will be ridiculous I think if I
put it the other way and I said I'm a
comment writer for the time so every
Monday you will all wake up if your
times readers with no ideas in your head
and you will then gain your opinions
from what I tell you you'd all think I
was patronizing and stupid no but and
yet that's the kind of idea you get of
Media power sometimes so I don't buy the
idea of Media power quite like that I
think it's a conversation between people
I think big media institutions and the
time is a very good example follow their
readers as much as they lead them and
the brexit referendum was a very good
case in point where all of the senior
people at the times were brexiteers all
of them but the times readers were 7030
for remaining of the European Union so
the paper took that view it absolutely
took that view because it was following
its readers commercial decision it's got
nothing to do with any propaganda or
anything like that pure capitalism and
that happens all the time that
institutions follow their readers as
much as they lead them so I don't buy
this sort of tabularasa view of the
people that they're simply taking in I
think it's patronizing one final thought
the media does expand a bit it doesn't
it's not entirely inelastic so when
Jeremy Corbin was leader of the labor
party for example a few voices did
emerge who were Pro Corbin voices as
indeed they should have done you know
Owen Jones Ash Saka Grace Blakeley Aaron
bastani there were people out there who
were Pro Corbin voices probably not
enough but nevertheless it wasn't
entirely impervious to change well I
mean again some really interesting ideas
here I mean I actually find myself
appropriately enough kind of I agree
with elements of of of both of what my
fellow panelists have said and then I
sort of think I might be diverging up
again in and yet in other direction so
the idea that you would have um certain
regulatory organizations or institutions
that somehow I mean Phil if I follow you
correctly what we're almost talking
about is sort of creating some
regulatory bodies that actually are
almost slightly out of the flow of the
Practical realities of what media and
journalism are today because it already
we have it already I'm obligations BBC
and icv and channel 4 exactly so we we
have those mechanisms in place and we
ought to be sort of giving them sort of
tougher or more robust Powers perhaps or
maybe trying to to extend their their
capacity not just to advise but to
actually act or impose certain guidance
that's interesting I think actually I
would be I would come back to Matt's
point this idea about what actually what
we what's really at stake and what I
think I would say is important going
forward is is to do plurality in media
better and actually have genuinely more
I mean so there's two ways you can you
can do you can approach this sort of
impartiality or you can either say right
well we're going to represent a lot more
viewpoints we're going to do so
thoroughly not in a sort of quick shock
jock flash headline way or a way that's
been incredibly marginalized I don't
know if anyone's following at the moment
some of the very um fraught media
coverage of the voice debate in
Australia which is heading into a
referendum about whether indigenous
people should have a permanent voice in
Parliament and that is a classic example
of how actually um there's a there's an
absolute barrage of media coverage on
this topic constantly and yet actually
if you drill into it a bit closer you're
talking um very few genuinely diverse
different sorts of opinions
represented I must admit Matt as someone
who sort of leftwood leading but sort of
um not kind of institutionally committed
shall we say um I'm I'm quite thrilled
to hear that the left's doing so well
because it doesn't look like that from
our angle that we you know we conquered
the universities and uh We've conquered
the it really doesn't feel like it it
actually feels like the the complete
opposite and it actually I think you
know again representing a diverse
Viewpoint here would say that actually
we're hearing the other voices coming
through louder and stronger and clearer
and that's why I mentioned the Australia
case for example where what you've got
there is quite an incredible case study
of going in to that referendum we had a
clear lead for the traditionally liberal
kind of yes vote Yes we should have a
committee in camra for indigenous people
excellent that's what that's what we all
want and then an astonishing combination
of the right and the rights ability to
tell stories that the media can pick up
and spread quickly and not just through
traditional media but other forms of
this new online World which I think is
is just so resistant to any form of
traditional regulation um we've had a
complete change a complete
transformation of that result and it is
not looking good for the yes vote come
October so I suppose I'm interested in
following up or going further with this
idea of how you genuinely do plurality
in the media yeah I think the other
question we have to ask here at this
juncture as well is who is evaluating
truth because that has become obviously
a an incredibly important central
question not only in newsrooms across
the world but also in households at the
dinner table we now sit around many
people families and argue about what is
true which is something that I think is
you know Donald Trump spoke to when he
said that we were kind of a bit over
truth we' we'd gone past the era of
Truth and into a kind of posttruth age
um perhaps he is also someone who's
who's been part of that I I think uh
speaking about regulatory bodies is
difficult here with that in mind because
of course how do we ensure that those
bodies are trying to fulfill uh an urge
to a striving for actual truth if we are
so unsure ourselves as to what actual
truth
is well that's for you Matt that's a big
one for
Matt yeah I'm going to come back to that
let me just quickly pick up let me just
quickly pick up on the University's
point and then I'm going to come back to
the truth Point CU in a way even though
we're talking about the media there is
probably no institution in society that
you know proclaims itself to be as
committed to truth and objectivity and
impartiality as universities and if you
don't think universities lean to the
left I would be really curious to see
what your day-to-day experience is like
in your University because in my view
and let me be provocative because we're
not all here to to get along and agree
let me just say one thing the
universities in this country have
completely given up on any pretense to
be objective independent impartial and
institutions okay and if you disagree
with that give me one day and I'll give
you a tour of universities and show you
what I mean they become openly political
organizations and in some ways that's
how they started they started as very
religious institutions that were pushing
an agenda but in the mid 20th century
late 20th century there was an attempt
to commit to truth seeking and
impartiality and objectivity today that
is simply no longer the case ideological
lipus tests are used across the board if
you want to get research grants if you
want to get jobs if you want to get
promoted if you challenge the liberal
consensus if you challenge things like
gender identity Theory opposition to
brexit particular interpretations of
British
history uh you basically will experience
some form of indirect or direct
discrimination and if you want the
evidence of that there's a lovely book
in the tent over there called Valley's
voice and virtue which will present all
of the evidence to you and the reason I
point to that is because in a way it's
reflective of what's happening in other
aspects of our national life um for
those who do challenge this narrow
Orthodoxy within our um Public Square
that is basically anti-
brexit PR globalization Pro migration
socially liberal um which basically
speaks to about 20% of the country if
you look at the British social attit UD
survey uh the latest edition came out
last week it suggests that 20% of
Britain are strongly and consistently
socially liberal on a whole range of
issues if you challenge some of those
assumptions some of those
beliefs um you are variously told that
you are buying into
misinformation that you are um pursuing
half truths or you have been manipulated
by media and so on and so forth to the
point where even fact Checkers and
reality checks and so on if you look at
them closely are basically becoming
openly partisan is what I would argue
can I can can I just just just so if you
if you challenge this
consensus you will find yourself um
essentially being gaslit by many
institutions so if you ask yourself the
question why are so many people
rebelling politically culturally
socially it is because when they look at
these institutions they do not see
people like them who reflect their world
view what can we do about it to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit I a.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas